[Music]
kim kardashian's daughter northwest has
had it with the paparazzi and she's
making her message loud and clear you
just gotta roll with it check out this
video kim shared of the encounter
between the nine-year-old and
photographers at the jean-paul gaultier
show at paris fashion week that's
northey holding up her invite to the
runway show with a twist a plea for the
paparazzi to stop photographing her
[Music]
the beauty mogul writes alongside the
clip for anyone who knows north knows
how funny she finds the last slide north
i guess had it with the people taking
pictures of her so she wrote on her
invite stop and held it up and wanted
them to just focus on the show she
definitely has kanye's outgoing
personality
and will say whatever is on her mind
no matter what it is or
who it might offend
um and then she's also really calm and
sweet like me sometimes but that wasn't
the first message northey sent the peps
at a prior fashion week event she asked
them a very direct question why do you
have to wait for us all the time yeah
north's not afraid to let him know how
she really feels why do you have to wait
for us all the time seems like she just
wants to enjoy her trip with her mom
which they've been doing all week kim
shared these fun snaps from the louvre
check out north looking at the mona lisa
a selfie of the two with a rooftop
painting and this pic of northie and her
friend ryan with the eiffel tower behind
them it's always so much fun
oh and it comes as no surprise the mama
daughter duo have been bringing their
fashion a game at the same couture show
north told the peps to stop they had
this twinning moment
sporting identical nose rings and
similar pinstripe looks north wearing a
vest and skirt and her mom a dress
they also paired their looks with
sunglasses to match
yeah bible it's a great look alongside
the pics of their time at the runway
show kim gushed about their girls trip
which also included her momager kris
jenner and wrote as a mom i'm so
grateful that my daughter loves coming
with me on my work trips and i am able
to bring her and create these memories
together along with my mom
yeah memories to last a lifetime there's
just that one part north will maybe
choose to forget
[Music]
you